لم يكن الأمر سهلاً على الإطلاق، لكنه لن
يكون سهلاً وبالطبع نأمل ألا
يمر العالم بما
نشهده اليوم من المزيد من
الكراهية والمزيد من الحروب والمزيد من
القضايا حول العالم ولكن أعتقد أن
هذا أكثر  كما لو كان الأمر مقلقًا كما لو كان
مقلقًا ويجب على الناس أن
يأخذوا الأمر على محمل الجد حقًا، وعندما نتحدث عن
سوريا كما لو أن الأمر لا يحدث فقط عندما
نتحدث عن أوكرانيا مثل فلسطين، فإن
بلدانًا أخرى حول العالم مثل
هذا يحدث بينما نتحدث اليوم
وأصبح الأمر أكثر خطورة.  عاجل وهذا مثل 110
مليون
لاجئ، إنهم ليسوا مجرد أرقام
والعدد يتزايد كل يوم،
وهذا أعتقد حقًا أنني
سأشجع الناس على أخذ الأمر
بجدية أكبر للنظر إلى حياتهم للنظر
إلى حياة الآخرين بالطريقة الوحيدة  بالنسبة لنا، فإن
النجاة من هذا الجنون هو أكثر وقاحة
وأكثر حبًا لبعضنا البعض،
وشعوب العالم هي حق
الناس وليس الحكومات وليس
القيادة، إنها شعوب العالم
التي هي الجماهير حيث الأغلبية
وإذا اخترنا  أن نقف إلى جانب بعضنا البعض
إذا اجتمعنا معًا، يبدو الأمر
ثوريًا للغاية، وهذا كما
تعلمون مثاليًا ولكن هذا صحيح نحن نحن، لقد
رأينا هذا في التاريخ حيث
ينهض الناس ويقررون أنهم يريدون
العيش بطريقة معينة  لقد
رأينا ذلك معًا داخل البلدان، ولم
نشاهده بنفس القدر على مستوى العالم في بعض الأحيان